t
[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus pour regarder qu'à
première le magazine consacré à la 34e
édition de ce tour de la martinique des
yoles rondes pendant toute la semaine
avec williams seront requins de cet
événement sportif et festif unique au
monde la 4e étape est partie de chez
elle cher pour arriver ici aux anses
d'arlet connu notamment pour ses
magnifiques plages
au programme de votre magazine
l'ambiance la course et les analyses de
notre spécialiste
justement williams commençons tout de
suite avec les résultats vers l'étape du
jour c'est pour cela
[Musique]
brasserie lorraine sahara cette aide et
mdf hôtel brise marine rosette/orange
ufr jean-florent zapetti l'appaloosa
depuis le début du tour jamais une
course n'a connu autant de leaders
différents des attaques des contre
attaques et un finish hallucinant auront
marqué cette quatrième étape un parcours
entre chelle cher et les anses d'arlet
première voie à laisser à tribord au
nord de porto et puis passage obligé
entre les deux bouts et de l'espace sud
au numéro 2 de petite anse à laisser à
bâbord avant d'aborder la troisième
marque de parcours juste avant d'arriver
dès le départ les mapipi annonce la
couleur les deux premiers au classement
général ufr champfleury brasserie
lorraine sa race surveille et c'est à
qui placera le premier une attaque
le tout sans se laisser surprendre par
rosette orange en embuscade
[Musique]
comme hier brasserie lorraine est plus
rapide que caraco dit l'équipage
marinois distance les robertins aidé
francis cas de l' arme fatale qui
s'accroche derrière les appétits
l'appaloosa est plus que jamais
concentré il faut à tout prix renverser
la tendance après un début de tour
catastrophique les embarcations ont pris
le large mais une bouée est à virer plus
à terre en face de porco et 7 à coki le
premier vient de bord suivi dans sa
manoeuvre par félix mérine tandis que
brasserie fait toujours course en tête
mais cette escapade en pleine mer va
coûter cher aux mapipi hôtel brise
marine lipton ice tea boucherie prudent
à garder un cap plus proche de l'avouer
et si tata se présente en tête quand
soudain surgit la voile noir de cette et
dm qui contourne la première la marque
de parcours
brasserie lorraine est deuxième zizi
tata occupe une fragile troisième place
l'évoqué - subissent l'assaut des frères
masse
suivent eu affaire jean flores et
rosette orange malgré une voile plus
petites c'était dm résista brasserie
lorraine
il faut dire que les laventinois sont
ici chez eux d'autres angoisses de
chance ce même en barque de l'eau
festival devassine abord ce marek
assiste de loin à la bataille de tête de
course
une tête de course aussi instable que
les vents tournants qui attendent les
embarcations s'étaient dm en tête suivie
une splendide attaque du fr qui prend
tous les risques avec succès
[Musique]
en digne héritier du père masse le wiki
laurent navigue près de la côte et
s'empare de la deuxième place
derrière brasserie lorraine s'accrocher
gare de ses adversaires en visuel
s'engage alors une guerre fratricide
entre franciscain félix mérine lui en
profite pour accentuer son avance mais à
trop savourer l'opportunité qui lui est
offerte les robertins en bas de l'écran
on en presque oublié de virer de bord
sanction immédiate
il dégringole à la quatrième place
rosette orange prend la tête de la
course
à côte qui n'a rien d'autre à faire que
de contrôler ses adversaires mais rien
n'est perdu
après le passage à la bouée numéro deux
c'est une nouvelle course qui commence
et qui dit nouvelle course dit nouveau
départ au pied du morne jacqueline les
yoles semblent s'aligner dans une
entente cordiale pour le sprint final
trois embarcations non 4 ufr chanflor je
veux tu être de la partie
à bord les hommes godille julien faire
touche le vent et s'empare de la tête de
la course passe la première l'avouer
numéro trois dans son sillage brasserie
rosette/orange la voile jaune qui tente
un coup et vire de bord tels
d'embarcations folle mérine rémy et les
'pharmas' attendent mais vire à leur
tour une bière stratégique à laquelle se
mêlent le jeu des priorités félix mérine
au plus près de la bouée jeunes tentent
de couvrir ses adversaires mr réussi ou
presque
c'est sans compter sur la soul ans des
frères masse qui lui grille la politesse
à une seconde
[Musique]
première victoire pour les franciscains
2 appétit l'appaloosa après 3 pour ce
très médiocre les frères maçons enfin
trouver le bon réglage au détriment du
fr champfleur deuxième tout s'est joué à
une seconde
moi ce cri dorel sarrail troisième
rosette orange 4e bon classement de
cette et des hameaux df 5e points il
devance est un peu moins bien que
d'habitude
10e tout de même mutuelle mare gaillard
est 11e
monsieur bricolage smartphone service
12e diab disque en espace santé optical
center termine le classement deux jours
sans victoire mais toujours le maillot
rouge pour ufr chanflor brasserie
lorraine sarah deuxième à 10 minutes
reste au contact
en revanche rosette/orange 3e à 33
minutes et 55 secondes vois ça me nuire
ces chances de victoire finale
à eelv on récolte les fruits de sa
régularité laguiole est quatrième devant
pas moins de trois matchs
brico bateau titans et 11e hôtel brise
marine 12e
tania chaussures est lanterne rouge un
plus de sept heures du leader
c'est la folie croyait yahoo désarroi
bousfer on leur a dit vous allez gagner
est là pour finir à noël et sa bête et
la captation
ça s'est joué sur le fil à l'arrivée non
jamais cela je vais jamais gagné la
foule n'a pas gagné je n'ai pas d'amis
je suis jamais pareil cette histoire là
c'est pour tout le françois sont loin au
général est ce que vous croyez encore la
victoire finale retardée des faits
champions faut toujours aller de l'avant
toujours en catégorie tout comme
aujourd'hui vous êtes heureux visiteurs
oui super super même si j'ai fait un
tabac gagner mais bon voilà investi a
fait le bon club ont commandé la bonne
stratégie mais bon voilà mes yeux est
fait avec toujours aller où je donne
c'est très bon c'est vraiment bon le
robert ont tout le monde est heureux sur
la plage était passé quelque chose de
magnifique à cette arrivée un magnifique
combat
c'est vrai qu'un magnifique combat c'est
vrai que c'était benoît la mano vraiment
et c'est un magnifique combat on est
très content
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on m'a dit que j'avais perdu le tour
non jamais l'applet perdu aujourd'hui
non
c'est parti fondée en 1902 toujours les
poignets a toujours la foi me levant ce
la meilleure dom et à la martinique
meilleure union
meierhans foot la commune la plus belle
la commune remplie tentative de la
martinique c'est le faux soir
[Applaudissements]
william comment as tu vécu cette arrivée
c'était fou une ambiance de folie
c'était extraordinaire vraiment ici aux
anses d'arlet c'était magnifique
à tel point je t'avoue qui avait
tellement d'ambiance que je n'ai pas
réussi à savoir qui était le gagnant
tout le monde était heureux 3e dans un
mouchoir de poche
écoute comment on va savoir parole aux
patrons pour savoir ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas mal ma piscine
[Musique]
comment c est quand même un petit
bourgeois soutient donc on a pas se
faire je la joue et c'est normal on a
peu touché la veille de l'arrivée c'est
bien mais après c'est dans la gfa être
fou du soir à +10 sinon on va se battre
jusqu'au bout
et là c'est la malchance pauvres à
l'automne l'état de vaud mais n'arrivent
toujours pas
bon
dans le mobile
d'emblée comme
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon signe vous
étiez en tête de course il ya eu un
combat mano à mano avec ufr un moment
donné qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
je pense qu'il avait plutôt parce que
nous on n'a pas voulu y aller non plus
beau après le buste de rester au contact
avec lui je pense qu'on arrive à brûler
ou jugé pascal de fenêtres de toit se
veut non plus très bon après tout on
leur rend d autant qu avec lui ses
licenciés ou non
mais ce classement à barbès est de
mettre à nu on va essayer de grignoter
encore du temps sur le concurrent est le
symbole à montanes un besoin ponctuel
aeromexico bien au vent donc de manager
une fellation fac la stratégie
commettrait en place on était tout près
de la victoire après on savait que ici
l'arrivée se joue quasiment toujours au
sprint ici on peut être devin et à un
kilomètre de l'arrivée gnole peut donner
une minute mais effectivement on est
passé tout près mais tout près ce n'est
pas gagné donc ça ne suffit pas passer
au lamentin au 6 août où notre commune
de base donc on avait à coeur de
rattraper déjà à nous trois étapes
ratées du des big toe on est au mois
d'août on a dit on va rectifier tout ça
je le mois d'août très bien on a montré
qu'on pouvait jouer devant on est passé
en tête leur métier devient une première
satisfaction
malheureusement par rapport à la surface
de balle qui était peut-être un peu plus
petit que les autres dans la période du
cap salomon nous ont rattrapés et
dépassés mais on a limité la casse en
35e
[Musique]
des allez les gars là c'est incroyable
on est déjà à la quatrième étape
on est à mi parcours et pour les
organismes des coursiers fabien très
difficile le temps passe vite et puis la
fatigue arrive je me demande d'ailleurs
toi williams était pas un peu fatigué
aujourd'hui pas du même genre comme
dhabi
parce qu'il paraît qu'on t'a vu à l'acte
auriol hier alors que tout le monde
comprenne bien de quoi enfin comme c'est
un acte auriol williams la furieuse ces
nouvelles ip ordinaire aussi bien à
terre qu'en bateau c'est toujours très
survolté bdta exactement je trouve que
tu connais très très bien nous en disent
pas tous les actes auriol la preuve avec
notre séquence coulisses d'hier où j'ai
été le chercher à l'afp oriol j'étais
pas trouvé c'est vrai c'était pas moi il
paraît qu'ils y étaient vous allez voir
[Musique]
salut à tous
cela lui valut à lui
risque était le tour des yoles mais qui
le gros avec le gros famille
voilà la chose comme ça aux antilles on
fait bien fait nous mêmes
ja
j'attendais la convivialité de basses
eaux en bateau son intérieur sur les
verts toute ta vie trop partage du monde
fait tout de suite en italie numéro 6 en
évitant une tête de mignot mais ospina
[Musique]
tu as vu williams miss usa miss
m'intéresse mais il est déjà parti
william je vais te trouver un je vais te
trouver c'est oui les bains il est venu
il a fait la fête avec nous et là est
déjà reparti des terribles et a en tout
cas elle là il a été très très très
heureux willem féminin se vide ne
voulait peut-être sur un català bah là
bas il avait la musique en train de
profiter de l'extérieur je crois
il était là tu alors là il est parti
sais pas pourquoi mais il était là tu as
les relais les profits ça y est j'ai
trouvé mon taxi williams j'arrête de
chercher franchement profite de la fête
moi de mon côté j'ai aussi ma muse et
lâcheté riols c'est comme ça je le
conseille vivement
alors tu bois tiga cela c'est local et
un sexe à cornet pistache mais à
l'intérieur c'est des cacahuètes ne me
demande pas pourquoi mais c'est comme ça
c'est important
merci je voyais absolument évident à
mangeant pas aussi pour moi et tu vois
pour être violent ou qu'on va dans un
match de football
on adore grignoter ça c'est génial papa
ni la compagnie des meilleurs alors
finalement tu y étais enfant en meriem
pour l'extérieur
j étais pas d'ailleurs ça qui fait tant
lembeye pas car ça veut dire que ça veut
dire ce qui s'est passé en mer ne se
répète pas à terre j'arrête de tentes de
taguine et agréable une chose est sûre
ces cuillères nos caméras elle était en
mer et air d'été sur la yole de gfa
caraïbes
c'est notre séquence caméra embarquée en
tilleul là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on prend un départ quand mes moyens
un plan resto sur l'option terre les
actuelles portent au lounge
les banques s'affolent pas et on fait
toute la traversée de la baie de saint
pierre à fond ça nous permet de recoller
tout le monde et on jouait le groupe de
tête à la bouée de bellefontaine
consorts de bellefontaine fois qu'on
entame la robotique se retrouve en
troisième position et jusque là tout va
bien
et quand l'avons soit aussi bon là on a
beaucoup souffert jusqu'à ce que des
salles et une fois qu'on des salles
bandes sermat et la 32f r8 copé a le
moins de temps possible
[Musique]
on a déjà fait des tours par le passé on
a eu beaucoup de monde la difficulté
c'est comme quand on est sur la côte
caraïbe
il ya de très bonnes accélérations le
relief accélère tôt donc voilà c'est
plus compliqué le moins - et habitations
des sur le côté atlantique la gestion de
l'équipage il doit nous permettre
d'avoir toujours les hommes feraient à
bonds afin que le travail soit toujours
performant un groupe violent ce n'est
pas uniquement 14 nous sommes 28 et on a
besoin de tout le monde sur la yole donc
à chaque condition ben il ya quelqu'un
qui rentre et cette rotation permet à
tout le monde de pouvoir voir cet angle
récupération ou donner 100% une fois
qu'ils sont bons
on fait 7e on est capable de le faire
nettement plus et jusqu'aux dernier
jours ben on va travailler pour être sûr
podium
[Musique]
sans lui
tous les jours dans votre magazine
quatre premières ont décrit une des
parties de laguiole et aujourd'hui il
s'agit du bois dressés un élément
essentiel au coursier pour tenir la yole
en équilibre directement et il
semblerait même que certains course et
ont une relation très fusionnelle avec
le roi de la belle coupe sur cette seule
monsieur bricolage nicolas me confiait
que vous voulez pas de bois dressés 9
pour lui son bois il ya un côté affectif
est attaché il ya une histoire
absolument
on vous dit tout sur le bois dressés
tout notre rubrique technique yonne
[Musique]
le bois dressés et réalisé avec un
arbrisseau ou un assemblage de bois il
mesure entre 3 mètres 50 et 4 mètres 50
le bois dressés peines de sept à huit
traditionnellement les coursiers vont en
forêt chercher du bois d'inde de
l'épicerie ou encore du bois côte
la coupe se fait après la pleine lune
selon les anciens c'est le moment où la
sève est au pied de l'arbre
ce qui permet un meilleur séchage
l'écorcé retirer le bois façonnés
aujourd'hui certains boisson fabriquée
avec un assemblage de bois collés
le bois dressés à une durée de vie de 4
à 10 ans ils coûtent jusqu'à 100 euros
le bois dressés est un support de rappel
m
[Musique]
le bois de récit est essentielle pour
permettre aux coursiers de faire le
contrepoids de la voile jusqu'à dix
hommes exécute un véritable ballet
synchroniser sur leurs bois pour
équilibrer la yole en fonction de la
force du vent le vent est puissant plus
il faut aller à l'extrémité du bois qui
doit être solide et flexible
les organismes sont soumis à rude
épreuve certains changements sont alors
opérer pour allégée ou alourdie en
laguiole en fonction du vent parfois cet
exercice peut s'avérer périlleux
[Musique]
c'est plutôt cher ami le tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes il faut le
vivre pour le croire
aujourd'hui l'étape à laquelle nous
avons assisté était digne d'un des
meilleurs films de suspense au moins
trois yole dans un mouchoir de poche
il a eu du spectacle de l'émotion
c'était fou était dingue et je pense que
ça mérite un vrai décryptage de
spécialités place à jean trudeau c'est
notre coq teillol nous avions des choses
cas difficiles au joug du salat était
tout d'abord changement le parcours
réduction du parc où on ne va plus
passée la passe défaut ni le rocher du
diamant
la direction de course a voulu un petit
peu soulagé les corps endolori des
côtiers les voiles de 60 m² à 37 ans à
peu près tout et puis on s'est dit que
la cause devait jouer à la bouée de coco
et à chaque marque doit pas qu il y a eu
des leaders différents tout ça tout ça
pour une arrivée mais vraiment une
arrivée au finish entre quatre yeux
celle qui efface toujours fait le petit
bourg de terre le même petit bogue dans
la baie de fort-de-france est arrivé à
couper la ligne en premier devant les c4
se tiennent en une minute sur elle la
ligne d'arrivée aux allées d'eux mêmes
et alors demain demain comme dirait qu
ami alexandre défunt camille une étape
de montagne
pourquoi parce qu'on s'entende des ans
d'aller une fois qu'on a passé lance
couleurs on va aborder le monde
jacqueline à partir du board jacqueline
je peux vous dire que le choix des
voiles sera pas important il paie un
beau temps parce qu'on va rentrer dans
la mer il va falloir vraiment cette
place des faucons à éviter aujourd'hui
il va falloir la faire demain passé
entre le rocher latéral et vilaine
bouille à sainte-luce ventre à terre
donc quelles que soient les bords qu'on
fait venir des plus arriver la prune
borgne est centrée dans le cul de sac du
mari j'ai une petite idée en fait non
pas celui là mon petit doigt me dit que
georges henri lagier jeanny rémy envie
d'arriver avec brasserie lorraine du
marin en tête aux marins
on est comme il ya la plage du bourg d
en parler est tellement jolie
regarde-moi et turquoise orange
et wahaha oui j'aimerais bien mais
bâtisse huit places au profil de l'étape
de demain entre les anses d'arlet et le
marin c'est notre séquence caf la gym à
4 donc à plat c'est la rubrique du
magazine
dimanche imag ap non tout va bien ouais
j'ai pas cas d'urgence
oh
comment
[Musique]
5e étape parlé le marin une étape de
montagne comme aurait dit camille
alexandre départ à 10 heures de la plage
du bourg d installer avec les
difficultés que nous connaissons le long
de l'a pas ce défaut
passage obligatoire entre le rocher du
diamant et la terre et commencé à tirer
de longboard contrôle vers cette marque
numéro un qui est situé à st plus face à
la pointe les fous sachant qu'il s'agit
d'une navigation au plus près il y aura
des yoles bâbord amure il va d'ailleurs
tribord amure les laguiole tribord amure
est prioritaire
le passage doit s'effectuer entre la
main que numéro un et la terre toujours
continué à tirer des bords des bords de
plus près le vent et serrer le vent
devant pour aller contourner cette
fameuse pointe bord et niaise avant
d'entrer dans le cul-de-sac du marin
toujours continué à tirer des bords
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée et ses deux
bruits qui sont mouillés devant la plage
du marais
[Musique]
la première demande et mon quotidien
consacré le tour de la personnalité
terminé pour aujourd'hui
rien tu as une bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer et oui on se retrouve demain
venez nombreux à l'arrivée de la 5e
étape au marin les coursiers ont besoin
de votre soutien et l'ambiance sera
chaude
on se retrouve évidemment amateurs sur
martinique 1ère et à 70,35 france
[Musique]
m
moi pas
que la dame qui
m
on adore
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]